Jennifer is going to start off this hour
from Houston Texas hi Jennifer how are
you hey Dave thank you so much for
taking my call to find her to talk to
you or you too what's up in your world
I'm trying to figure out I have a
daughter that 20 years old who is just a
huge problem in our house we've got
three other kids and she's just verbally
abusive to me so I need to get her out
of the house and I'm trying to figure
out how to do it money-wise I feel like
I should either set her up in an
apartment or give her I told my husband
$1,000 to see if she can figure it out
and he saying no we shouldn't do any of
this that she'll just use this and come
back anyway so I was wondering what your
thought is so is your husband her father
um not her biological father he we've
been married since she was two so I mean
he's some kind of man allows a 20 year
old to be abusive to his wife cuz I
gotta tell you that happen at my house
I've been laying on the floor looking up
you might talk to your mom that way but
you don't talk to my wife that way he
has said things to her before and he I
guess she's very supportive of whatever
I say and so I guess I try to control
the situation all the time I try to walk
on eggshells make sure not to set her
off and now that one what I was talking
about this this man is allowing someone
to speak abusively to his wife why well
she does I do it inside of him she
usually waits when he's not home well
why why would he allow it period
I don't know I gotta tell you one of my
kids start that they're gonna find their
butt in the gutter okay nobody talks to
Sharon Ramsey that way with well I'm
alive well I don't know what I don't
know I don't either because I'm telling
you that's the issue here you know cuz
here's what I heard I heard you're gonna
give her money and she's gonna come back
anyway because nobody among you or your
husband has the backbone to stand up to
this little twerp well you know you're
right yeah I mean you need to throw her
butt in the street she needs to learn a
lesson or two
but it's a little late I mean you waited
20 years to discipline her so high man
you got a mess yeah I think you give her
some money but you need to have real you
know give her a thousand bucks I don't
care it's worth thousand dollars now I
have a conversation like this so but get
her out of the house and explain to her
and you and your husband need to join
hands lock hands and say she's not
coming back here ever except to visit
and have dinner and only then if she
cannot be abusive okay period I mean you
guys you guys got a unify and stand up
to this disaster together and if you
don't do that nothing you do is going to
work does that make sense to you it does
make sense it's a whole lot harder to
do's and you know when you're saying it
you know that's the right thing to do
but then when you're doing it because
we've tried back in June to try to kick
her out and then it never happened
because she promised that she would stop
I don't care she what she promises she's
leaving okay okay what she promises and
you think it's okay to give her a
thousand bucks it's okay but but it's
not okay to do that unless the two of
you have established first and foremost
that no one is going to walk inside our
the walls of our home and speak to you
this way ever under any circumstances
it's totally unacceptable okay you know
let me tell you this if a stranger did
that you'd have him arrested oh I would
yes absolutely yeah so so why are we
putting up with this crap off of
somebody that you raised and diapered
and fed well it's guilt because he's
thankful they are acting this way
because you've obviously made them this
way and some inform some how well you've
allowed it so in that sense you've
contributed to it but just the same that
doesn't mean it can't be corrected
because I mean I've got grown children
they're my youngest is 21 but you know
that there's something you look at your
mom and say the rest of your life as
long as daddy's breathing and that's yes
ma'am right that's what you live in her
himself yeah I don't think my mom that
way or anybody and you know why she
would have knocked you in the next week
yes what
yeah yeah that's why right and lower and
said I love you and that's why I'm doing
this because you're not going to grow up
and be one of these kinds of people that
thinks you can talk to people this way
and behave this way
so you guys are enabling the behavior
and it won't matter what you do to get
her out until the two of you join hands
and love this child enough to make her
be respectful of her mom period because
she's not going to come in here and talk
to me that way Duke not going to happen
we'll have her hauled out of here with
some bracelets that connect you know is
there you go that's how it works
hey thanks for the call